Caption: yeah
Caption: alrighty guys thank you for coming to
Caption: our talk today so today we've actually
Caption: got a fellow Telstra purple senior
Caption: consultant with us Brenton 80. he'll be
Caption: doing a talk on training a PowerPoint AI
Caption: to play Tic-Tac-Toe now he is actually a
Caption: tutor also for the University of Western
Caption: Australia data and analytics boot camp
Caption: he's got a pretty interesting background
Caption: with a Bachelor of Science majoring in
Caption: maths and psychological science and a
Caption: master of Applied Artificial
Caption: Intelligence on the way
Caption: daughter is a rapidly growing domain and
Caption: it is his vision to spread awareness of
Caption: the power that comes with taking control
Caption: of data over to you Brinton wonderful
Caption: cool
Caption: so uh pretty provocative title there uh
Caption: a little bit click-baity uh surely this
Caption: is just a trick you might say just like
Caption: a play on words to get you through those
Caption: doors and don't worry we will get into
Caption: it we will get into this magical
Caption: PowerPoint AI
Caption: but before I talk about that we need to
Caption: understand what AI is what artificial
Caption: intelligence is
Caption: more specifically we're going to talk
Caption: about one Avenue that we get through to
Caption: get to AI which is machine learning
Caption: so before we go any further
Caption: feel like I do have to warn you guys
Caption: this isn't actually a talk about
Caption: PowerPoint or tic-tac-toe
Caption: if you came in here hoping to get the
Caption: latest tips and tricks on creating
Caption: flashy slide decks and and mastering the
Caption: game of tic-tac-toe then well one I'm
Caption: profoundly sorry and two you maybe
Caption: should have read the talk description a
Caption: little bit more
Caption: there's time to leave if you want um
Caption: but AI then
Caption: AI is a term that floats around a lot
Caption: these days it's usually is some ex
Caption: machina style magic to solve all of the
Caption: world's problems which I mean it's great
Caption: for me because it means that I get to
Caption: wander around pretending like I'm some
Caption: Chris Angel in my day job analyzing data
Caption: but you see a magician never Reveals His
Caption: Secrets the difference here me a data
Caption: scientist I'm going to take you behind
Caption: the curtain and see how simple machine
Caption: learning and AI really are and how
Caption: applicable it is to so many different
Caption: scenarios more than you might expect
Caption: even say
Caption: a PowerPoint
Caption: but if we're going to talk about machine
Caption: learning and some of you might be aware
Caption: of this then there's something we can't
Caption: avoid talking about
Caption: maths
Caption: that's right I tricked you all into a 45
Caption: minute lecture I'm grueling repetitive
Caption: complex maths
Caption: who's excited
Caption: except
Caption: we don't really need to talk about maths
Caption: to talk about machine learning
Caption: as much as I would love to get into
Caption: intricacies of stochastic gradient
Caption: descent or cross-entropy loss between
Caption: distributions those of you who just felt
Caption: the blood rush from your face as I
Caption: mentioned the word maths can relax just
Caption: a little bit
Caption: but then that begs the question if we're
Caption: not going to talk about maths
Caption: what are we going to talk about
Caption: you see if you looked on the definition
Caption: of machine learning from our friendly
Caption: site Wikipedia you would get
Caption: machine learning algorithms build a
Caption: model based on Sample data known as
Caption: training data in order to make
Caption: predictions decisions without being
Caption: explicitly programmed to do so
Caption: that bit's important so keep it in the
Caption: back of your mind
Caption: but this is wild right this must be some
Caption: wild new innovation we've got sample
Caption: data we're making predictions and
Caption: decisions
Caption: except this quote is often attributed to
Caption: someone called Arthur Samuel
Caption: in 1952
Caption: Arthur Samuel was a pioneer of machine
Caption: learning in IBM and he was Building
Caption: Systems to play Checkers right back in
Caption: 1949.
Caption: but what about all this stuff I'm
Caption: hearing about neural networks computer
Caption: vision surely being able to get a
Caption: computer to see images that must be new
Caption: and wild right
Caption: this is a schematic for the Mark 1
Caption: perceptron this and is an initial
Caption: machine learning algorithm that was
Caption: trying to mimic the workings of the
Caption: human mind which sounds super fancy it
Caption: was used in early computer vision models
Caption: to for image recognition
Caption: in 1957
Caption: now although the technology has changed
Caption: a little bit the same fundamental
Caption: principles are still being used today
Caption: and are solely responsible for the
Caption: Resurgence we saw in neural networks in
Caption: 1990s
Caption: this might be a bit strange not what you
Caption: would expect
Caption: but you see despite what the buzzwords
Caption: might say machine learning is not just
Caption: for Big Data
Caption: machine learning is not just for
Caption: large-scale compute for people who have
Caption: all the money in the world to throw at
Caption: which maybe Microsoft will get mad at me
Caption: for saying um
Caption: machine learning is it's not Magic
Caption: if that's what machine learning is not
Caption: then what is machine learning
Caption: we're going to talk about what machine
Caption: learning is and hopefully by the end of
Caption: this you'll be able to come on me with
Caption: the come with me on the journey to how
Caption: we can create machine learning out of
Caption: something
Caption: stupid
Caption: machine learning is a way of
Caption: constructing a model that describes
Caption: things about the real world without
Caption: having to explicitly program it every
Caption: detail
Caption: in a way it's about transferring
Caption: Knowledge from the unknown from the
Caption: known to the unknown
Caption: and we do this sort of learning in real
Caption: day lives every day so much so that it's
Caption: pretty much second nature
Caption: when I was a kid I spent a lot of hours
Caption: playing the guitar
Caption: probably should have spent more hours
Caption: doing my hair
Caption: this is the sacrifices we make right
Caption: except for one time in high school where
Caption: we were auditioning for a musical which
Caption: the mic is important
Caption: um and maybe five six upwards of that
Caption: amount of people were trying to audition
Caption: for guitar but no one was auditioning
Caption: for Bass and I said
Caption: how hard can it be going from six
Caption: strings to four
Caption: easy
Caption: except any musician who is tried to
Caption: transfer from guitar to Bass will know
Caption: that there are transferable skills
Caption: there's a lot more knowledge that you
Caption: need to gain before you can successfully
Caption: play the bass my first few performances
Caption: I absolutely bombed
Caption: I thought I started out thinking that I
Caption: would have all my knowledge in guitar
Caption: that would easily transfer it into
Caption: um bass but this wasn't the case it was
Caption: only after successive practicing
Caption: learnings failings that I managed to get
Caption: to where I am today
Caption: put it another way let's assume we have
Caption: a group of people much like yourselves
Caption: tasked with predicting the result of a
Caption: coin flip
Caption: and for every correct guess you get a
Caption: cookie that's just so that we make sure
Caption: that people take this very serious
Caption: experiment seriously
Caption: without prior knowledge except for the
Caption: fact that maybe a coin has two sides I
Caption: think we can agree within a certain
Caption: margin of error that 50 of the group
Caption: will get a cookie
Caption: so we run this one flip turns up heads
Caption: two flips turns up heads
Caption: three flips heads and what a coincidence
Caption: some might say others might start to
Caption: catch on
Caption: four flips turns up heads
Caption: five flips turns up heads and a group
Caption: start might start getting suspicious
Caption: cookies are flying left and right
Caption: given enough time people will learn the
Caption: ploy of this con man
Caption: it is no ordinary coin
Caption: the group starts around here 50 percent
Caption: but then with successive coin flips and
Caption: the promise of cookies getting ever more
Caption: enticing we start to learn with coins
Caption: true nature nature
Caption: by guessing and getting it wrong or
Caption: guessing and getting it right and being
Caption: rewarded constantly over and over again
Caption: we can start to induce that the
Caption: information is not that the coin is a
Caption: regular coin but it is a double-sided
Caption: double-headed coin
Caption: so
Caption: what is that how can we abstract that
Caption: away from that experience of us learning
Caption: after successive coin flips and apply it
Caption: to Something in the maths world or the
Caption: computer world
Caption: there are many types of machine learning
Caption: that you might have heard of supervised
Caption: unsupervised reinforcement learning
Caption: semi-supervised
Caption: but fundamentally they all follow the
Caption: same three basic steps
Caption: we need to create a test
Caption: what is the model trying to do
Caption: we need to define a way to score the
Caption: test
Caption: how well do we how do we tell if a model
Caption: is good or bad or what it's trying to do
Caption: and lastly most importantly we need to
Caption: find a way to punish or reward the model
Caption: for the score it received
Caption: so again the idea here is that if we
Caption: take the fundamental components of what
Caption: a machine learning algorithm is
Caption: stripping away all the maths complexity
Caption: and high compute power we can find ways
Caption: to implement it in something simple and
Caption: we need to know these steps if we're
Caption: going to build an AI from the ground up
Caption: with machine learning in say
Caption: a PowerPoint maybe I don't know is that
Caption: why you're here
Caption: indulge me for a minute while we walk
Caption: down metaphor Lane
Caption: we're going to open up Brenton School of
Caption: machine learning studies
Caption: in this school we have students day in
Caption: day out trying to produce results
Caption: school is the model and our students are
Caption: just instances of training that model
Caption: get this school to learn and perform in
Caption: one of the top schools we need to define
Caption: a test
Caption: this test is how we're going to judge
Caption: how well the school performs when we
Caption: conduct a test each student will get a
Caption: score and our student score is and our
Caption: school score is some aggregation of the
Caption: student score
Caption: who doesn't love standardized tests
Caption: right
Caption: after the test we need to Define what it
Caption: means to pass or fail it
Caption: what does it mean for a student to do
Caption: well in the test what is a good score
Caption: what is a bad score for the school
Caption: what will end us end up in US losing
Caption: funding and turning off the lights
Caption: forever
Caption: lastly we need to Define how we're going
Caption: to punish the students who have failed
Caption: and reward those who did well
Caption: this is a standardized test and again
Caption: our score will be based off the
Caption: aggregated score of all of our students
Caption: so we want to maximize the amount of
Caption: students passing
Caption: by whatever means necessary
Caption: and we do this many many times
Caption: each time a student is getting punished
Caption: if it gets the test wrong or it's
Caption: getting rewarded if it's doing it better
Caption: it's important to note here that the
Caption: students are the one learning after each
Caption: test they are what makes this machine
Caption: learning school a machine learning model
Caption: and you can't just go ahead and reward
Caption: or punish a school in as a whole anyone
Caption: who's tried to organize any group of
Caption: kids will know that that's just not
Caption: possible what you do have control over
Caption: is the individual students running their
Caption: tests and you have the ability to learn
Caption: to get them to learn or change their
Caption: scores
Caption: now you might say a different approach
Caption: to this is to try and get every student
Caption: to memorize the answer of every single
Caption: test question in the test which yes it's
Caption: an option it will get a pretty good
Caption: score but then say a new school board
Caption: runs around and says we don't like this
Caption: test we're going to define a new one all
Caption: of a sudden you have to do all of the
Caption: rework and getting all of these hundreds
Caption: thousands of students in the school to
Caption: relearn their answers it's not efficient
Caption: and I know that I can't memorize a
Caption: standardized test for the best of days
Caption: the key thing here is that you can run a
Caption: test on any model but if there exists no
Caption: process to punish or reward the model
Caption: based on the test score then it's simply
Caption: not a machine learning model
Caption: so that's a little bit of fun down
Caption: metaphor Lane but let's look at this in
Caption: the real world
Caption: what you're looking at here is an
Caption: example of the mnist data set it's sort
Caption: of said as the hello world of computer
Caption: vision whatever that's worth
Caption: data set containing 70 000 labeled
Caption: handwritten digits
Caption: uh 10 60 000 of those are training in
Caption: six ten thousand of those are testing
Caption: the name of the game is to get a model
Caption: that classifies an unseen hand written
Caption: digit as zero through to nine
Caption: so in this case our test is pretty
Caption: simple is the predicted digit equal to
Caption: the actual labeled digit
Caption: so if we try and approach this in the
Caption: simplest way possible
Caption: our first model might be
Caption: random guess
Caption: this is about as simple as we can get we
Caption: just simply ran get randomly guess a
Caption: number between 0 and 9 and assign the
Caption: label to be that
Caption: this model is quite easy to test
Caption: actually in fact if we did it then we
Caption: would find that it's about 10 accurate
Caption: and that's much like guessing a random
Caption: coin is 50 right accurate
Caption: however
Caption: we have no way to change the model's
Caption: behavior when it gets things right or we
Caption: can't alter it when it gets things wrong
Caption: our model's accuracy will always be 10
Caption: percent
Caption: hence I'm a model is not a machine
Caption: learning model
Caption: so 10 percent not that great one in
Caption: every 10 digit gets it wrong
Caption: so let's try a better approach
Caption: this time we're going to relate a model
Caption: to the image's darkness which might seem
Caption: a bit strange but you might expect an
Caption: image of an 8 to be darker than an image
Caption: of a one and maybe a little bit darker
Caption: of an image of a three it's more ink
Caption: involved so there's more Darkness
Caption: this model is a little bit better in
Caption: practice we see that the accuracy
Caption: averages to about 22 percent which is
Caption: twice as good as randomly guessing
Caption: but it's still only one in four one in
Caption: five getting it right
Caption: I think
Caption: we can do better than that
Caption: crucially again there was no way to
Caption: alter the model's Behavior
Caption: when it's dark and it predicts it to be
Caption: an eight it'll always do that regardless
Caption: if it was just a really heavily uh
Caption: highlighted five
Caption: so let's see if we can apply what we
Caption: just learned in the school metaphor for
Caption: creating machine learning algorithms
Caption: don't worry about the code in two
Caption: details this is an extract taken from a
Caption: book that I dearly love called neural
Caption: networks and deep learning by Michael
Caption: Nielsen
Caption: uh for those interested this is uh what
Caption: this is again what we call a neural
Caption: network
Caption: but crucially what this has is what the
Caption: other two models didn't it has a way to
Caption: reward good test scores and punish bad
Caption: ones
Caption: every times it runs its own tests it'll
Caption: find a way to calculate how different
Caption: the predicted value was from the
Caption: expected value
Caption: and then alter the model in some way
Caption: that favors the way that it got it right
Caption: the key magic in here is uh we feed
Caption: fraud back propagation approach this
Caption: takes the output of a cost function
Caption: cross entropy in this case to test how
Caption: how different the prediction was from
Caption: the expected and it Alters the model uh
Caption: based on stochastic gradient descent
Caption: which honestly it's pretty simple it's
Caption: just based on the train rule of deriving
Caption: matrices
Caption: except I said no maths
Caption: I'll break
Caption: the model here is a machine learning
Caption: model
Caption: it had a test the is the predicted value
Caption: equal to the actual labeled digit
Caption: it has a way of determining a good or
Caption: bad score in this case I said it was the
Caption: cross entropy function
Caption: and it has a way of altering the model's
Caption: Behavior the stochastic gradient descent
Caption: don't have to know how it works you just
Caption: have to know that it's there and there's
Caption: a method of applying this punishment or
Caption: reward
Caption: but
Caption: the mnist is a pretty typical example I
Caption: said it was like the hello world of
Caption: computer vision
Caption: in it we had a very clear labeled
Caption: objective
Caption: if our model
Caption: didn't predict the correct label for the
Caption: digit then it's not up to scratch
Caption: sometimes the test and the score aren't
Caption: so clear-cut
Caption: the interest interesting examples in the
Caption: industry around the test isn't so clear
Caption: and a bad score is equally just as vague
Caption: see labeling digits is easy
Caption: but what about if you're trying to just
Caption: transcribe somebody's piano playing and
Caption: as an audio file and transcribe that
Caption: into manuscript music that somebody
Caption: would read
Caption: this is a paper uh called onsets and
Caption: Frames dual objective piano
Caption: transcription and they try to do just
Caption: that
Caption: now the paper is full of fun maths and
Caption: data science jargon but the point of
Caption: Interest here is when the authors tried
Caption: to describe how they base the model
Caption: accuracy for velocity
Caption: as they say it's been a pretty hard nut
Caption: to crack I mean sure you can tell if a
Caption: note written on paper is the same as the
Caption: note what was played you can even test
Caption: whether the transcribe for note falls on
Caption: the same beat give or take
Caption: but how do you capture Dynamics volume
Caption: expression
Caption: a note pitch is a note pitch but what
Caption: reference does a note's loudness have
Caption: who's to say the recording just isn't
Caption: really loud or there's a lot of
Caption: background noise
Caption: additionally how do you correct a given
Caption: notes volume based on the content when
Caption: the context that it appears in is
Caption: arguably more important
Caption: a soft note compared to a really loud
Caption: note
Caption: has different uh meanings than if you
Caption: just have a sequence of soft notes
Caption: so I love academic papers the authors
Caption: are kind of hand wavy at this point
Caption: they're saying that they've discovered a
Caption: never-before-seen method to truly test
Caption: whether their model perfectly
Caption: transcribes the Dynamics of a player
Caption: Forte fortissimo piano
Caption: however it's important to note that all
Caption: that's been done is some math magic to
Caption: calculate a score based on the average
Caption: volume of the recording
Caption: they didn't discover any brand new
Caption: method they simply defined a test
Caption: the test could have easily been all
Caption: notes of the correct volume if they're
Caption: below negative five decibels
Caption: that's a test and the model would have
Caption: been really good at transcribing all
Caption: notes that are below negative five
Caption: decibels
Caption: so these are the three key things that
Caption: we've got to keep in our minds moving
Caption: forward
Caption: to have a machine learning model you
Caption: have to have a test
Caption: a score and then a way to punish or
Caption: award based on that score
Caption: sometimes these are pretty easy to
Caption: understand say for example if is your
Caption: digit equal to the labeled digit
Caption: sometimes it can be a bit more vague in
Caption: the case of when you're trying to
Caption: transcribe music notes or when you're
Caption: trying to
Caption: play Tic-Tac-Toe for example
Caption: so that was a lot
Caption: but this creates the fundamentals of
Caption: what we're going to use as we go through
Caption: the Journey on how you might do
Caption: something strange
Caption: see machine learning is more than just
Caption: classification and regression
Caption: machine learning can be used in any
Caption: application that uses the three key
Caption: principles when you define a test when
Caption: you calculate a score and then provide
Caption: some sort of punishment or reward
Caption: and if you don't believe me well
Caption: this is where the fun comes in
Caption: training an AI to play Tic-tac-toe
Caption: except
Caption: that might not really get you convinced
Caption: right maybe I'm just going to pull out
Caption: my Python and do some math magic and
Caption: then that doesn't convince you at all
Caption: what about if we tried to find a
Caption: scenario in which we didn't have any of
Caption: that available to us we don't have any
Caption: code we don't have any fancy compute
Caption: yeah I think this will do a better job
Caption: I mentioned before Arthur Samuel who
Caption: spent a large part of his career
Caption: utilizing the best IBM computers at the
Caption: time to create revolutionary new machine
Caption: learning programs
Caption: I wonder what he'd think if he saw his
Caption: whole what life's work reduced to a
Caption: slide deck
Caption: now inter typical consultant fashion I
Caption: will label some caveats here and really
Caption: Define the scope of what we're going to
Caption: be working with
Caption: the aim of the game is to demonstrate
Caption: that machine learning is no more
Caption: complicated than any other algorithm
Caption: once stripped down to its fundamentals
Caption: hence
Caption: no code is allowed
Caption: now full disclosure I did use some
Caption: macros as you will soon see to get this
Caption: working involved many slides and
Caption: many
Caption: many animations
Caption: so
Caption: to save myself an eternity I hacked some
Caption: old VBA scripts to automate the
Caption: insertion of animations and slides we
Caption: will not be using these in the method
Caption: for training the PowerPoint I want to
Caption: make that very clear
Caption: secondly
Caption: for the game theorists out there there
Caption: is about uh 255
Caption: 168 possible games of tic-tac-toe
Caption: this number varies slightly depending on
Caption: how you define what a game of
Caption: tic-tac-toe is but needless to say
Caption: that's a very big number
Caption: um so to narrow this down I've reduced
Caption: the problem to training a PowerPoint
Caption: tic-tac-toe to win in three moves or
Caption: more likely it's uh training a
Caption: tic-tac-toe to not lose in three moves
Caption: but you know that doesn't that's not as
Caption: catchy
Caption: in addition the AI will always make the
Caption: first move and always in a corner
Caption: see the game of tic-tac-toe actually
Caption: varies quite significantly depending on
Caption: which player goes first so we're going
Caption: to just highlight one example of this
Caption: game state
Caption: where possible we will utilize
Caption: Reflections and rotations so that a
Caption: computer will never make a move that is
Caption: a reflection or rotation of another
Caption: state that it can move to
Caption: what does that mean in this example
Caption: there are only three places that an AI
Caption: will try to place
Caption: itself
Caption: the left the bottom left and then the
Caption: bottom
Caption: this is because the other blank spaces
Caption: are just reflections of those moves the
Caption: right and bottom right are just
Caption: reflections of the left and bottom left
Caption: us human players will have no such
Caption: restrictions
Caption: this leaves us with a still not tiny
Caption: number of
Caption: 1830 possible game states that you can
Caption: have for Tic-tac-toe
Caption: um I'll take the time here to thank the
Caption: inspiration uh that cursed me with this
Caption: uh project uh first was the work by
Caption: mathematician and comedian uh there are
Caption: some of us who are funny by the name of
Caption: Matt Parker who ran a project and
Caption: training a machine learning algorithm to
Caption: play Tic-Tac-Toe based on a set of
Caption: matchboxes and this was off the work of
Caption: Donald Mickey in 1961.
Caption: if you ask me they're kind of cheating a
Caption: little bit they only have to deal with
Caption: this approximately 700 possible states
Caption: that the tic-tac-toe board can be in and
Caption: there was a lot of human intervention so
Caption: you know not throwing any shade but
Caption: the second uh was a video by Tom
Caption: wilderhane who really opened my eyes to
Caption: the programming potential of PowerPoint
Caption: in his uh absurd ideas in computer
Caption: science PowerPoint programming uh it's a
Caption: great watch
Caption: so PowerPoint then
Caption: now I've heard from the streets that
Caption: some people are under the false
Caption: impression that PowerPoint is not the
Caption: greatest tool ever invented
Caption: well if I'm shocked I mean PowerPoint
Caption: has literally everything you could want
Caption: from a programming language
Caption: it has text
Caption: it has
Caption: shapes
Caption: and most importantly
Caption: has animations
Caption: that's a totally random animation by the
Caption: way the first time I'm seeing it it's
Caption: always fun
Caption: you may laugh but the shapes and
Caption: animations actually the key to what
Caption: allow us to form a real machine learning
Caption: model with PowerPoint
Caption: because they allow us to do something
Caption: that developers take for granted every
Caption: day
Caption: State Management
Caption: in our model each slide will represent a
Caption: particular move from either the player
Caption: or the AI
Caption: we will then use these shapes and
Caption: animations to manage that state to
Caption: remember what they learn
Caption: so our model will consist of 1830 states
Caption: which is one thousand eight hundred and
Caption: thirty slides
Caption: each slide State consists of the
Caption: following
Caption: simply the board which is the number of
Caption: naughts and crosses in their relative
Caption: positions to each other
Caption: um in this case AI is cross and human
Caption: player is not uh that just felt right I
Caption: don't know
Caption: and also we all contain all of the
Caption: previous steps that got us to that state
Caption: using uh one of my favorite PowerPoint
Caption: features Zoom transitions
Caption: so this encodes all of the information
Caption: that got us to the state that we were in
Caption: it allows us to bop but back propagate
Caption: through each path and get to the slide
Caption: that led up to it
Caption: so that's the state that's what we're
Caption: trying to capture in a slide but how do
Caption: you transition from one state to another
Caption: well there are two different types of
Caption: turns there's a player's turn and an
Caption: ai's turn
Caption: for the player a collection of shapes
Caption: that place a naught and navigate to the
Caption: relevant slide are on every single Blank
Caption: Space
Caption: they're invisible so they don't have any
Caption: fill color or outline color but they do
Caption: have a hyperlink to the slide that is
Caption: relevant
Caption: every click on an empty space navigates
Caption: the user to a new slide where that knot
Caption: is in the location that was clicked so
Caption: for this slide there are eight invisible
Caption: shapes but they are there and they
Caption: hyperlink to the relevant slide when a
Caption: user clicks one
Caption: we go to that slide and notice in the
Caption: top left hand corner we've saved the
Caption: state of what it was previously by using
Caption: the zoom transition
Caption: so that's the player but what about the
Caption: AI how do we get the AI to navigate
Caption: and this is where things get interesting
Caption: now to be sure a human player still
Caption: clicks the AI we're not building a
Caption: PowerPoint to control a mouse just yet
Caption: although don't give me any ideas
Caption: for the AI there is also a collection of
Caption: invisible shapes but these these ones
Caption: blink at semi-random intervals the
Caption: difference between this navigation and
Caption: the previous navigation is that all the
Caption: shapes are in the same place except only
Caption: one is visible at a given time
Caption: when a user clicks on the button labeled
Caption: click to make AI move I have no ux
Caption: designer but that's pretty
Caption: self-explanatory it instigates the
Caption: animations of each shape lawet clicking
Caption: so this is for demonstration in reality
Caption: those shapes are invisible and they're
Caption: clicking they're blinking a lot faster
Caption: and there's a lot more of them
Caption: so that's it
Caption: our model consists of
Caption: 1830 game stats 301 of those each have
Caption: an AI making a random choice to proceed
Caption: to the next move
Caption: now I say random Choice currently we're
Caption: set at a ground state for the model
Caption: and think of ground state as just
Caption: predicting 50 50 on a coin toss
Caption: what we want to do is to change from
Caption: that ground state into a state that is
Caption: optimized for playing Tic-Tac-Toe
Caption: how are we going to do that
Caption: let's call back to what we learned just
Caption: a few minutes ago
Caption: we're going to use machine learning so
Caption: we need to define a test
Caption: a score and a way to punish or award the
Caption: AI for making bad or good moves
Caption: so if we do this we can verify that what
Caption: we've indeed created is a machine
Caption: learning model an AI for in a PowerPoint
Caption: to play Tic-tac-toe
Caption: first our test
Caption: due to the limited time of a lone man's
Caption: calendar and the absurd amount of games
Caption: of tic-tac-toe I said that this test is
Caption: does the AI win in three moves the
Caption: converse is true does the AI lose in
Caption: three moves
Caption: next our score
Caption: now the number of winning games is not
Caption: evenly distributed among the total
Caption: number of games of tic-tac-toe what I
Caption: mean by that is there are far more games
Caption: where neither the player nor the AI win
Caption: so for this score we're going to
Caption: consider three results pass the AI wins
Caption: neutral neither the player nor the AI
Caption: wins and three the AI losers
Caption: passing represents the best possible
Caption: score that we could get and we want to
Caption: encourage this as much as possible
Caption: because it happens so few times
Caption: the failing is a bit more common but we
Caption: want to discourage this from happening
Caption: and neutral is pretty much the most
Caption: common
Caption: so
Caption: this translates to how we're going to
Caption: punish a reward
Caption: when an AI passes and it wins in the
Caption: first three moves we want to give it an
Caption: extra chance so that it will navigate to
Caption: each slide that leads to a winning move
Caption: that's signified by a plus three chance
Caption: neutral nothing happens we don't want
Caption: our AI to just lose all of its chances
Caption: to navigate
Caption: fail is we take away the chance to
Caption: navigate to the particular slide that
Caption: made it end up in a losing position
Caption: so
Caption: how are we actually going to do this
Caption: this is the fun bit this is the reason
Caption: why we had to have that absurd uh
Caption: arrangement of shapes blinking and all
Caption: of them on the slide
Caption: it's also why we have to stay save the
Caption: previous state that we're in throughout
Caption: the whole path of the game
Caption: so I said that each move in the AI state
Caption: has a
Caption: absurd amount of blinking shapes now
Caption: these shapes represent the probability
Caption: of moving from one state to another
Caption: in the ground state I've initialized it
Caption: with 10 shapes each to move to each
Caption: available location than a I can move
Caption: into
Caption: in this slide there are 70 7 places that
Caption: the AI can move to they're the blank
Caption: spaces because there's no symmetry here
Caption: and because there's a initialized for
Caption: the 10 shapes each to navigate to those
Caption: slides there are 70 randomly blinking
Caption: shapes on this slide
Caption: each one representing a chance to
Caption: navigate to the state that we're going
Caption: to move to
Caption: so
Caption: when an AI runs a test if the results
Caption: were good that is the AI wins in the
Caption: first three moves then we'll track the
Caption: moves it took to get to that state this
Caption: represents the best possible play that
Caption: an AI can make somewhere along the line
Caption: the player has made a mistake and the AI
Caption: has a chance to win and it does
Caption: we want to reward this as much as
Caption: possible
Caption: what I mean by that is we want to reward
Caption: every state that came before it to
Caption: appear again
Caption: so
Caption: we add more of those shapes that are
Caption: randomly blinking the hyperlink to those
Caption: slides
Caption: and we back propagate through every
Caption: state with that so it starts with no
Caption: things no pieces on the board
Caption: when we click the AR moves we want to
Caption: encourage it then to move to the next
Caption: state in which it will win
Caption: however
Caption: let's say the AI makes a bad play
Caption: somewhere along the line it might have
Caption: even had a chance to win
Caption: but then it doesn't it makes some sort
Caption: of fatal error and leaves it open for
Caption: the player to come in and attack
Caption: we want to discourage this from
Caption: happening if it's in a position where it
Caption: can either win or Draw
Caption: we don't want it then navigating to a
Caption: slide which represents a state that a
Caption: player can then win
Caption: so every time we run a test and it loses
Caption: we back propagate through every slide
Caption: that we have and take away one of those
Caption: shapes that navigates to the slide that
Caption: ends up losing
Caption: and that's for every single slide along
Caption: the path
Caption: this way when it's at a fork in the road
Caption: when it doesn't know where to put it
Caption: there is more chance that it will move
Caption: to a slide that wins or is neutral but
Caption: there is less chance that it's going to
Caption: navigate to a slide that loses
Caption: if the test is neutral that is neither
Caption: the player nor the AI win we simply just
Caption: do nothing
Caption: so this is an AI That's initialized with
Caption: random choices but you'll be able to see
Caption: as we go forward how it works
Caption: the player is just put in the center and
Caption: we click again to make the AI move
Caption: in this case the randomly blinking
Caption: shapes promoted us to navigate to a
Caption: slide there
Caption: now a player made a mistake there the AI
Caption: has a chance to win here an optimized
Caption: model would put it on the top
Caption: but because there's an equal chance
Caption: currently for the AI to click onto the
Caption: navigate to the wrong slide it doesn't
Caption: it makes a mistake we're going to
Caption: discourage this from happening by
Caption: navigating back through every slide and
Caption: taking away one of those randomly
Caption: blinking shapes so that if it's ever in
Caption: the same position again it has less
Caption: chance to navigate to that losing slide
Caption: and then
Caption: we do it again
Caption: the AI will make a move in the top left
Caption: hand corner and the player will make
Caption: another move
Caption: this time the air made a different move
Caption: it's setting itself up right to win but
Caption: a player blocks it
Caption: player has a chance to win so an
Caption: optimized AI with all the navigation
Caption: shapes configured correctly we'll try
Caption: and put it in the bottom but again it
Caption: makes a mistake so moving forward we
Caption: discourage that by taking away every
Caption: shape that leads to this state
Caption: from the PowerPoint deck
Caption: and this is a long grueling process
Caption: there is a question that I'm sure a lot
Caption: of you have been asking throughout all
Caption: of this
Caption: how many games
Caption: um
Caption: to be sure I mean it's great to say what
Caption: machine learning is not maybe break the
Caption: stigma how it can be used but why does
Caption: the fundamentals of the understanding of
Caption: machine learning matter besides the fun
Caption: of knowledge for knowledge's sake why
Caption: did I go through this whole process of
Caption: constructing a way to train a PowerPoint
Caption: to go through a machine learning
Caption: algorithm
Caption: what I hope is clear by now is the
Caption: distinction between traditional control
Caption: logic and the Machine learning approach
Caption: and that's all it is an approach
Caption: the difference suggests a fundamental
Caption: change in how we conduct analysis build
Caption: Automation and program
Caption: any other models we saw predicting a
Caption: digit based on its Darkness or randomly
Caption: guessing are examples of this
Caption: traditional logic if this then that
Caption: however machine learning if nothing else
Caption: is a tool that allows us to move past
Caption: this constrained test
Caption: it's not possible to know every then
Caption: this and it's certainly too time
Caption: consuming to label every then that
Caption: machine learning allows us to tackle
Caption: problems that we couldn't possibly know
Caption: how to tackle
Caption: machine learning is not just predicting
Caption: digits or analyzing text sentiment but
Caption: any process in which we can test score
Caption: and provide feedback
Caption: all of the advancements in machine
Caption: learning the maths the the distributed
Caption: compute are just ways that we can extend
Caption: this process of creating fancy tests
Caption: scoring it and then running it again
Caption: in cases like I said the cross-entropy
Caption: loss which sounds pretty fancy but all
Caption: it is is a way of getting our list of
Caption: numbers that we predicted and the list
Caption: of numbers that we expected and doing a
Caption: calculating a score that is kind of easy
Caption: to comprehend
Caption: sometimes it's not as easy so the
Caption: researchers have to go above and beyond
Caption: to try and think about what they're even
Caption: trying to test
Caption: an example like the audio transcription
Caption: paper that we saw where they were faced
Caption: with a problem that isn't immediately
Caption: obvious what we do so they rather than
Caption: diving into let's just pump it with more
Caption: compute power it was let's take a step
Caption: back and what is it that we're even
Caption: trying to test it's the other Dynamics
Caption: correct
Caption: in a PowerPoint example
Caption: it's not
Caption: how can we somehow make some code in
Caption: PowerPoint although PowerPoint is true
Caption: and complete
Caption: um
Caption: it's a way of analyzing what we have to
Caption: work with shapes slides and animations
Caption: and how can we use those to do the
Caption: fundamental components of testing
Caption: scoring and providing feedback
Caption: by adding and subtracting shapes the
Caption: animation allows us to navigate through
Caption: States but it simply taking away and
Caption: adding shapes that allows us to provide
Caption: feedback
Caption: in the end machine learning Taps into
Caption: something that we take for granted but
Caption: applies it in a programmatic way
Caption: it's our ability to learn before knowing
Caption: so thank you
Caption: on the slides here I have uh some of the
Caption: resources that I did mention neural
Caption: networks in deep learning is the book
Caption: All Around the fundamentals of neural
Caption: networks I started using the terms AI
Caption: Machining a little bit interchangeably
Caption: but as I mentioned way at the beginning
Caption: machine learning is just one Avenue that
Caption: allows us to get through Ai and it's one
Caption: of the most popular and it's certainly
Caption: useful
Caption: neural networks is another subset of
Caption: machine learning this particular
Caption: interest of mine but if anyone's
Caption: interested in learning more I recommend
Caption: that book
Caption: Onsen and Frames dual objective piano
Caption: transcription is the paper that I maybe
Caption: flippantly was uh reviewing I want to be
Caption: clear that the Google lab team and
Caption: everyone that worked on that the
Caption: incredible work but it does provide a
Caption: good example of how in the real world
Caption: sometimes how we test and how we score
Caption: isn't immediately obvious
Caption: Menace the pile of matchboxes which can
Caption: learn if you want to look at this but
Caption: done in matchboxes have a go at that but
Caption: I mean they cheated right they had a
Caption: whole bunch of people working on this
Caption: was just me and a PowerPoint
Caption: which is a lot sadder than now I'm
Caption: saying it out loud
Caption: and lastly great impractical ideas
Caption: computer science PowerPoint programming
Caption: is a hoot it's a long one but if you
Caption: want to see a turing machine in
Caption: PowerPoint there's your go
Caption: sh if you're interested in a follow-up
Caption: you can add me on Twitter LinkedIn you
Caption: can go to the blog site that I
Caption: occasionally write
Caption: um
Caption: I do have a working version of this
Caption: PowerPoint AI as you saw in the video
Caption: it's not yet optimized for playing
Caption: Tic-Tac-Toe perfectly because it takes
Caption: many many iterations of running the test
Caption: adding and subtracting the shapes and my
Caption: friends didn't find that interesting on
Caption: a Saturday night so um yeah please reach
Caption: out to me if you're interested in
Caption: versing a PowerPoint in tic-tac-toe
Caption: I lastly want to thank all of the
Caption: sponsors for DDD they're the people who
Caption: allow us me to stand up here and talk
Caption: about something that I have no right to
Caption: be uh talking about a PowerPoint AI
Caption: um and also thank you to all the
Caption: volunteers who work up very early today
Caption: to get this all working
Caption: thank you
Caption: I think we have time for some questions
Caption: practically on time so we've got five
Caption: minutes for questions if you wanna yeah
Caption: I think we've got a question there yeah
Caption: oh thanks so you said machine learning
Caption: is one of the ways to do AI what are the
Caption: ways yeah AI is like about as broad as
Caption: term as you can get some people consider
Caption: things like statistical models and
Caption: everything to be part of AI so that's
Caption: not something that users an iterative
Caption: approach
Caption: um but you know things like probability
Caption: tests and t-tests other people uh
Caption: natural language processing is a really
Caption: interesting example of AI that isn't
Caption: machine learning because there's a whole
Caption: bunch of still maths linear algebra and
Caption: stuff but they don't do the iterative
Caption: approach they just do like Vector
Caption: multiplication and stuff like that
Caption: that's simplifying it a lot but there
Caption: are yeah those are some of the examples
Caption: next question
Caption: um I was pretty impressed with what
Caption: we've seen today but I just wanted to
Caption: ask what's next what's next next oh well
Caption: I mean go is one of the most complicated
Caption: games you can play Maybe
Caption: no
Caption: um I don't know I mean to be honest this
Caption: is just a fun example maybe I've spent
Caption: too much time on it but it it was more
Caption: of an exploration into
Caption: how fundamental machine learning
Caption: actually is
Caption: um I'm not sure I'd do something like
Caption: this again
Caption: um yeah unless you sat me down in a
Caption: torture room but um I can't stress
Caption: enough how many hours it was to form
Caption: that board
Caption: um but yeah I'm always Keen in
Caption: investigating these sort of weird
Caption: approaches so
Caption: uh anyone else lucky last question guys
Caption: anybody
Caption: wonderful oh we've got another one you
Caption: know I'll talk about this for hours oh
Caption: yeah um yeah I'll ask some of the
Caption: questions so I was just curious with the
Caption: um PowerPoints I never thought of it but
Caption: um did you say there's no code you just
Caption: literally have a PowerPoint that just
Caption: click through it yeah yeah yeah
Caption: someone was manually doing the um like
Caption: punishment and rewards yeah wow okay
Caption: yeah yeah like I said there was macros
Caption: involved to like insert the slides um
Caption: like I'm not gonna copy and paste 1 830
Caption: slides
Caption: um but yeah those those macros weren't
Caption: used for the actual training of it
Caption: because that kind of defeats the purpose
Caption: this would be
Caption: easy to do it in VBA or something like
Caption: that but it wouldn't it defeat the
Caption: purpose of the whole exercise I think
Caption: personally I mean maybe I'm just
Caption: sadistic but yeah
Caption: thank you so
Caption: thank you very much
Caption: that's it
Caption: all right guys in here in about 10
Caption: minutes we're gonna have George coldham
Caption: and swen Lee